As we go to our next game,
-Fashion Weak. Fashion Weak.
-Yes.
Last week, the Internet
was bombarded with pictures
from Fashion Week, because
no one's a better fashion critic
than someone on Facebook at 3:00
a.m. who's not wearing pants.
In addition
to the beautiful people
who've been artfully warped
by Photoshop's stretch tool,
there were also some, uh,
pretty warped outfits.
So I'm gonna show you a photo
from Fashion Week.
I would like you to tell me
the name of the look.
First up, this one. Tiffany.
Edward Scissorhands'
baby sister.
Yeah, points. Points.
Edward Scissor Sisters.
-All right, good.
-Yes.
Next up...
Yes, Andrew.
The Gucci Poochie.
Points.
Next up...
Theo.
Uh, there's really something
about Mary.
Yes, points.
Points.
Next one...
Tiffany.
Cousin It's coochie's out.
Yeah, points.
Points.
Next one...
Theo.
Big trouble
in Little Richard's basement.
Points. Points.
Points.
And finally, this one...
Yes, Andrew.
Dollar Store Deadpool.
-Yes! Oh, perfect!
-Ooh, that's good.
-That's good.
-Perfect! Points!
Fantastic.